this video is sponsored by skillshare
Cold practical precise loved by many
feared by all he is also a total
sociopath hi everyone welcome back to
the channel uh warning this is a book
video if you're afraid of books you know
Shield your eyes or something do do
something like January was a very
productive month for me in terms of
reading today I want to talk about the
new series that is my obsession I want
to explore some of its themes and
explain why I think it might be for you
if you're looking for a new type of
Series this series is quite old and it
was actually begun in the 60s the Parker
series by Richard Stark AKA Donald E
Westlake AKA many other pseudonyms
Parker series contains 20 something
novels have their own structure they're
all about the same character each novel
usually involves a heist there's usually
four or five parts to each novel always
a part that reverses the perspective so
we're always following Parker until
usually one part of the story we're
following the nemesis the Rival the
obstacle in the story someone different
we're following the Hunter for a while
and then we get to see perspective from
the prey before I continue here's a word
from our sponsor skillshare skillshare
is an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes for
creators explore new skills deepen
existing passions and get lost in
creativity with skillshare you all know
I'm a huge fan of skillshare I have a
great working relationship with them a
couple of classes I've been enjoying
lately are start drawing three fun
freeing exercises to spark your
creativity by Carly cook I used to
sketch and doodle all the time and I
happen to find this one and it's just
been really fun and liberating and I
feel like I've been doodling a lot more
relieve stress which is you know that's
a lot of what I like to look for stuff
that isn't high pressure and things that
I can feel like I've learned something
along the way I also really enjoyed
Nathaniel Drew's class he's a YouTuber a
great YouTuber he did one called
creativity Unleashed discover hone and
share your voice online but it was
really good uh practical but also sort
of a philosophical introduction to the
kind of problems and ways to solve just
kind of unblocking the fears with uh
creating things online and sharing
things out into the public space so you
can do it in bite size videos or watch
the full course it's curated
specifically for learning meaning there
are no ads you're always launching new
premium classes so you can stay focused
skillshare now offers classes in Spanish
French Portuguese and German the first
thousand people to click on the link in
the description get skillshare for free
for one Mungo check it out skillshare
it's great don't miss out back to the
video so who is Parker is introduced to
us in the first novel The Hunter a huge
man with massive hands immovable Force
but the most interesting part of him is
that he feels almost nothing so the
first novel is like a Revenge story um
he's going after the people who wronged
him who left him for dead in the
meantime he's like just killing people
not because he likes it Parker doesn't
like killing he only does it if he has
to do it the essence of like the
Protestant work ethic except without any
of the religion he is the most practical
human being he's like a machine and in
that sense Parker to me feels like the
prototype for the Terminator and scarier
I would say and what's so wonderful
about the writing is that it is so
stripped back it is lean it's really
precise but you're not getting any extra
stuff Parker doesn't have a ton of
internal thoughts besides what is
focused on the mission I believe part of
the suspense through each of the novels
is trying to see where does Parker crack
because it seems like he's a total
sociopath all he cares about is getting
the money doing the job right he's a
total professional but
there's still that hope like in our
brains we're still hoping out for a
little bit of humanity to peep through a
little bit of vulnerability you know
something to break but it doesn't happen
at least not yet where I am in the
series he's also a villain and the hero
of of the story the charm of the books
are all of the supporting characters the
villains the bad guys the uh you know
the the people in the outfit the people
in uh you know the other professional
you know career criminals so I am
reading currently my sixth Parker book
um I've been going through the series
Almost chronologically however I started
at I think at a good point which is the
12th novel I think called slay ground I
don't think it really matters where you
start in the series except that you read
the first three together one two and
three kind of follow this Arc of Parkers
dealing with organized crime he's
basically a wanted man he's upset a lot
of people and he's having to deal with
the outfit most of the stories are
self-contained if you don't like Heist
stories I'm going to have no interest in
this if you are super character driven
reader you know this probably isn't for
you either the funds in the side
characters the plot in a way the series
shouldn't work because Parker is so
uncharismatic basically evil
um but he's our hero but he's not evil
in the sense like he enjoys cruelty he's
not like that he's just so good at his
job he's just trying to be so excellent
and in a way you kind of feel Westlake
the writer mirrored in that sense where
Westlake is channeling this pseudonym
Richard Stark to write these novels
about someone who is lean and tough and
is so precise with his abilities and in
a way the novels themselves are just
these lean tough exercises in craft they
are so brilliantly written on just like
a scene by scene line by line basis that
you kind of have to Marvel at the powers
of of Westlake and the powers of Parker
one thing to note these are old older
books the series continues until like
the early 2000s I think so the or the
90s the early ones you know they were
written in the 60s very problematic
depictions I mean there's some
homophobic but very sexist stereotypes
as well like of its time for sure it
doesn't consume the whole book they're
mostly like male Centric books the
female characters aren't always fleshed
out but then again I'm early in the
series that could change but for the
most part it's it's not it's not great
you know but they're also very
reflective of Parker's attitudes towards
human beings as just means to an end he
sees most people as just disposable he
doesn't believe in honor he just kind of
believes in efficiency in a way he's
kind of like a corporate CEO like he'd
make a great CEO so point of entrance to
the Parker series I personally recommend
reading slayground or just start
starting with the hunter just be warned
that the hunter I don't think the hunter
is the best one in the series it's it's
certainly Parker's kind of forming you
know in westlake's mind he wrote the
first novel to be a standalone
originally where Parker dies at the end
but uh publisher thought that Parker
should be a reoccurring character it
seems like westlake's always trying to
push Parker to his limits and see how he
can get out in this one there's a heist
that goes wrong and Parker gets trapped
this amusement park that's off season a
bunch of people are trying to get him
and his money that he has basically like
home alone in an amusement park
interesting and fun I know Westlake was
known for his humor when he was writing
under his own name Stark I think has his
own very dry sense of humor I Love the
Way Westlake really sets up the villains
and focuses on like humanizing the bad
guys in in any other any other writer I
think would just make them generic
generic gangster types then I went back
and read the second book in the series
called The Man and with the getaway
phase so a while ago I read the hunter I
enjoyed it but I had trouble getting
into the man with the getaway face which
immediately follows the hunter Parker
has plastic surgery to look different
basically he does an armored car robbery
that whole sequence is entertaining but
turned around with the consequences of
his uh plastic surgery and how that kind
of gets solved probably one of my
favorites I've read so far it was
surprisingly good then I read the outfit
wasn't as good as I was hoping however
it had some amazing almost like short
story vignettes where there's these
other criminals doing crimes in the
story and we get to see you know just
the way Westlake frames everything it
sets it up explains how the crime
syndicate Works in such a a clever uh
way then I read the mourner book Number
Four The mourner involves their they're
stealing a precious statue Parker's
dealing with people who are really
interested in art and storytelling and
how you know things gain value over the
years and Parker doesn't care about any
of that he's just trying to figure out
how to you know if he's getting paid for
it he'll do it he just doesn't care
about art or anything like that so it's
funny how he's having to deal with these
characters who do there's a really great
character who is like defecting who is
basically the villain in the story and
his POV section is so entertaining
because he's coming from a communist
country in the 60s to the US and has
this fantasy about being in the United
States and like cowboys and freedom and
like living this life of crime enough
funny and I actually thought uh the
mourner might be my favorite one so far
but I don't think most people love it
that much I thought it was really good
so I also want to mention some of the
other books I read I've been getting
into another series written by Lawrence
block which is a great former cop called
Matt Scudder started in the 70s but it
was written over many years it's another
one of those series that has a ton of
books accidentally killed a kid with a
ricocheted bullet doing favors kind of
living as a private eye they're really
well crap crafted Mysteries I will say
really well crafted really entertaining
the voice of Scudder is probably the
best part he has a kind of sad way about
him he's an alcoholic the first one is
called the sins of the fathers I thought
the mystery was really engaging it
involves a father trying to figure out
more about his daughter who was murdered
the biggest flaw to the sins of the
fathers is the conclusion where there's
some really bad 70s pop psychology going
on in Freudian terms uh some things
which was just really dated and really
clumsy and uncomfortable so that was a
big Downer for the sins of the fathers
the second one is called time to murder
and create I enjoyed a bit more trying
to figure out who killed this
blackmailer and there are three people
he's basically trying to investigate to
figure out who who killed this
blackmailer that one was really good and
the third one is called in the midst of
death probably not my favorite but it it
definitely Advanced scudder's story
forms a relationship with the wife of
someone who he who hired him what I like
about the books is that it is written
from the perspective of a former cop so
he has certain privileges with the
police but he's all he's very aware of
the corruption so there's a lot of it's
all about the the constant corruption in
society the people getting paid off how
the levels of power work cynical kind of
um engaging mystery series oh I also
read it starts with us
I hope you enjoyed listening to your
hearing me talk about the stuff I read
let me know if you've read anything good
lately I'm always up for a
recommendation yeah I hope you all have
a good one all right bye bye